[Aplausos]
[Música]
chechenia es una isla de integrismo
islámico en mitad de la rusia de
vladimir putin tal cual como lo es en
este país que presume ser la reserva
espiritual de occidente el último
baluarte de la cristiandad es donde se
encuentra la república de chechenia
[Música]
un lugar donde ni siquiera podemos
comprar vodka porque nadie se atreve a
venderlo y ya sé lo que me vais a decir
fonseca acabas de decir la república de
chechenia no habías dicho que esta es
una región dentro de rusia lo cierto es
que la federación rusa es el país más
grande del mundo en cuanto a territorio
y eso significa que su distribución
territorial es un auténtico rompecabezas
la mayor parte del país está dividido en
los llamados o blas que serían algo
parecido a los estados de eeuu tienen su
propio gobernador y su propio parlamento
pero siempre están supeditados a la
constitución y el gobierno de moscú
[Música]
sin embargo hay otras partes del país
que prácticamente funcionan como países
independientes tienen su propia
constitución su propio lenguaje y hasta
su propia religión oficial
una de estas repúblicas por ejemplo es
la de crimea aunque no esté reconocida
ni por eeuu ni por la unión europea de
facto está controlada por rusia veréis
en teoría la ley rusa garantiza
muchísima autonomía a estas repúblicas
[Música]
pero digo en teoría porque ya sabéis que
a vladimir putin le gusta tener todo el
país bajo control de hecho prácticamente
todos los presidentes de estas
repúblicas rusas pertenecen al partido
político de putin rusia unida y cuando
algunos de estos gobiernos se desvía
ligeramente de la línea del kremlin
pasan cosas como estas
cargas tan la última región en perder su
estatus especial bajo putin sin embargo
hay una república con la que putin no se
atreve sí sí habéis oído bien
vladimir putin el chuck norris de la
política también tiene que agachar la
cabeza de vez en cuando especialmente
cuando hablamos de chechenia
es difícil saber quién manda a quien los
observadores rusos en la región se
quejan de que la ley rusa y la autoridad
terminan en la frontera con chechenia
[Música]
por ejemplo en chechenia el uso del
'hiyab' se promueve desde el propio
gobierno la poligamia y los matrimonios
con menores de edad están tolerados y
ningún restaurante se atreve a abrir
durante el día en la época de ramadán
sin embargo cualquiera de estas cosas
palidece ante lo que la prensa ha
revelado en abril de este año 2017
[Música]
chin chin ya abre los primeros campos de
concentración para homosexuales vale es
cierto que vladimir putin tampoco es el
campeón de los derechos lgtb
precisamente pero abrir campos de
concentración son palabras mayores así
que la pregunta es por qué putin no se
atreve a imponer orden en chechenia que
tiene el presidente checheno ramzán
kadyrov para que putin le permite
acampar a sus anchas
hoy vamos a responder a esta pregunta
pero antes vamos a ver un poco de
historia
[Música]
la sicilia del cáucaso durante siglos
chechenia estaba gobernada por grandes
clanes que controlaban un territorio
cada uno de estos clanes conocidos con
el nombre de tulum estaba integrado por
cientos de familias lo que entreno se
llama los tape para que nos entendamos
era algo parecido al sistema de la mafia
siciliana todo quedaba entre familias
[Música]
y de la misma forma que la mafia
siciliana es un sistema político que ha
resistido a toda clase de invasiones
este sistema de túcume nos ha
sobrevivido tanto a los zares como a la
unión soviética
debemos ser soviéticos en público y
musulmanes en privado proverbio checheno
en otras palabras que durante la época
soviética existían dos sistemas
políticos paralelos por un lado el
comunismo oficial impuesto por moscú y
por el otro esta jerarquía de clanes
[Música]
por eso cuando en el año 1991 la unión
soviética desaparece los chechenos
aprovecharon este momento de debilidad y
declararon la república chechena de
histeria el nombre os sonará porque
salía en uno de los juegos de la saga
call of duty
e
el por entonces flamante presidente
democrático de la nueva federación rusa
borís yeltsin respondió con la fuerza
y el sinn declara el estado de
emergencia y el toque de queda en la
región de chechenia sin embargo este
estado de emergencia fracasó por
completo el ejército ruso fue incapaz de
frenar a los rebeldes chechenos y tuvo
que marcharse con el rabo entre las
piernas pero no sólo eso al marcharse
los separatistas terminaron quedándose
con buena parte del armamento que los
soldados habían dejado al marcharse a
moscú así que durante tres largos años
el kremlin tuvo que hacer la vista gorda
con chechenia sin embargo las cosas
cambiaron en el año 1994
puedes construir un trono con bayonetas
pero es difícil sentarse en el boris
yeltsin recordáis que os dije que el
sistema político de chechenia se basaba
en distintos clanes esos llamados to
whom que dominaban las distintas partes
de la república pues lo cierto es que no
se llevaban demasiado bien entre ellos y
por eso estalló una guerra civil en esta
república una guerra civil que desde el
kremlin se veía como una oportunidad
perfecta para recuperar el control
pero un año más tarde y después de que
el ejército ruso perdiera casi seis mil
soldados al bueno de boris y el sinn no
le quedó otro remedio que firmar un
acuerdo de paz con el gobierno de grozni
que por cierto es la capital de
chechenia un gobierno separatista y
absolutamente débil
mientras tanto muchos terroristas
islámicos de arabia saudita o afganistán
estaban volando a grozni para reclutar a
nuevos miembros a fin de cuentas un
estado fallido tribal y donde el islam
es la religión mayoritaria es el caldo
de cultivo perfecto para un terrorista
islámico en otras palabras que era
cuestión de tiempo que estallara otra
guerra en la zona y eso ocurrió en el
año 1999 cuando un grupo de rebeldes
islamistas chechenos invade la república
de al lado la república de daguestán
[Música]
es decir que no contentos con dar
problemas en su propio territorio los
chechenos estaban atacando otras partes
de rusia como os podéis imaginar el
kremlin tenía que enviar sus tropas de
nuevo pero esta vez era distinto si el
presidente seguía siendo boris yeltsin
pero el primer ministro era el único el
inigualable el mejor amigo de visual
político vladimir putin
[Música]
enseguida putin se puso en contacto con
uno de estos líderes separatistas
chechenos el señor ahmad kadírov así que
le dijo kadyrov como ven acá para acá
mira yo te voy a dar todas las armas y
el poder que necesites te voy a cubrir
de oro puedes hacer lo que quieras en
chechenia pero con una condición no
quiero ni guerras ni terrorismo y como
decimos en visual político dicho y hecho
[Música]
la guerra terminó y cándido utilizó
todas esas ayudas que le llegaban desde
el kremlin para reprimir a todos los
demás señores de la guerra que poblaban
su república y os preguntareis funciona
pues la respuesta es sí y a la vez no
por supuesto que las guerras terminaron
pero muchos de estos patriarcas
chechenos organizaron atentados
terroristas en otras zonas de rusia
incluida moscú
en el caso de moscú un grupo de
terroristas secuestraron a más de 300
civiles en un teatro de esos 300 rehenes
170 murieron
[Música]
en otras palabras que el plan tenía sus
fisuras y la autoridad de kadyrov era
cuanto menos discutible tanto es así que
unos años más tarde murió en otro
atentado terrorista en grafing y aquí es
cuando entró en escena el personaje
crucial de esta historia
[Música]
la estrella de instagram ramzán kadyrov
sucedió a su padre en el poder y
aprendió una valiosa lección si quieres
crear una dictadura hazlo a lo grande
hablamos de un lugar lleno de señores de
la guerra luchando entre ellos donde
organizaciones como al qaeda o el daes
se dedican a reclutar a nuevos miembros
que pueden desafiar a tu poder en otras
palabras que kadyrov juniors no estaba
dispuesto a dejar que esas cosas raras
de los demócratas como los derechos
humanos o la libertad de expresión le
quitaran el sueño
[Música]
además contaba con el apoyo el dinero y
las armas de putin que más se puede
pedir
le dimos la vida a putin se olvidará
esto no sería un hombre cuando pase por
un momento terrible en mi vida me ayudó
para mí es el hombre más santo lo cierto
es que desde que kadyrov hijo llegó al
poder los atentados de los terroristas
chechenos en suelo ruso han desaparecido
no sólo eso las células de al qaeda y el
daes están cayendo una tras otra la
policía de kadyrov les persigue les
expulsa del país junto con sus familias
o simplemente les quema la casa
por si todo esto fuera poco los soldados
de kadyrov se ofrecieron voluntarios
para las misiones más peligrosas de
ucrania es más para mostrar su amistad y
su amor eterno hacia putin tras nam
kadyrov organizó un enorme desfile
militar en el estadio de fútbol de
crossing
miles de militares clamaban al
presidente checheno dispuestos incluso a
morir por él
[Música]
si putin me dice que le mande mi
ejército estoy listo sin embargo las
cosas no son tan dulces como parecen en
este desfile militar kadyrov estaba
lanzando dos mensajes uno útil es mi
amigo y dos si algún día putin deja de
ser mi amigo aquí tengo un ejército que
me es leal dispuesto a morir y matar por
mí sí amigos de visual político si en
algún momento vladimir putin quisiera
enfrentarse a su viejo amigo cheché no
lo tendría bastante complicado y las
muestras de poder no son pocas
[Aplausos]
a todos los enemigos políticos de
kadyrov han sido asesinados
independientemente de donde estuvieran
desde periodistas residentes en moscú
hasta opositores políticos exiliados en
san petesburgo y qué significa todo esto
pues que el gobierno de grozni tiene a
su propia calle infiltrada por todo el
país y que no tiene ningún inconveniente
en utilizarlos cuando alguien sea éste
checheno o no se levante contra calidad
en otras palabras que putin creó a
razmán kadyrov y ahora es lo
suficientemente poderoso como para
mirarle frente a frente eso explica que
a diferencia de los presidentes de
cualquier otra república rusa kadyrov se
atreva a opinar públicamente sobre
asuntos de política internacional o que
el kremlin haga la vista gorda cuando
desde grozni deciden crear campos de
concentración de homosexuales
rusia apoya al gobierno de chechenia
cuando niega que haya matado y torturado
a homosexuales mientras tanto chechenia
es cada vez más rico gracias a rusia de
hecho el 90% de su riqueza viene
directamente del dinero que le envía el
kremlin y kadyrov ha creado una
república donde el culto al líder es
algo así como la segunda religión sólo
por detrás del islam
[Aplausos]
su cuenta de instagram tiene casi 3
millones de seguidores dos veces la
población chechena desde ahí podéis ver
el estilo de vida de uno de los
dictadores más salvajes del mundo y a la
vez el único al que putin tiene miedo
así que ahora la pregunta es llegaremos
a ver un enfrentamiento entre vladimir
putin y razonan kadyrov debería el
kremlin tratar de evitar las violaciones
de derechos humanos en chechenia podeis
dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios mientras tanto no olvidéis
que sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las
semanas así que suscribiros a este canal
para no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones si os ha gustado este
vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo un abrazo y hasta pronto
[Música]